[Music]
hello welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm constant in kiss and
this is the show for you if you're bored
of people arguing on the internet of the
subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we asked the experts our
fantastic expert guest this week is an
Australian economist the CEO of lateral
economics and the self-styled general
pontificate er nicholas grow and welcome
to check anoche higher constantine hi
Francis
[Music]
it's great to have you here listen
before those people who don't know you
just give us a little overview of who
you are what's been your journey through
life how are you way okay
so let me just say that my brother what
my father was a quite a prominent
economist in Australia and my brother
and I had to amp both of us had an
ambition not to become economist but
it's an important part of my story
because I knew I got an intuition about
economics long before I studied
economics and I found I went and worked
for our industry Minister a guy called
senator John button in the nineteen
eighties worked on car industry policy
and I found to my dismay that economics
was being used not as a method of
thinking but as a badge of tribal
identity if you were in a kind of you
were trained as an economist you knew
what you thought before you checked out
the subject and I've I realized now that
the company that I started many years
later which I called lateral economics I
actually have given a paper called
lateral economics a brand or a method
and I think it's a method and it's it's
the way I go about things which is to
stay away from precooked conclusions
whether they're in my discipline in any
other discipline or in politics or
anywhere else and so that leads me to
kind of figure stuff out for myself and
if that sounds like a cliche it is but
takes a long time to unlearn all the all
the things that you're being taught and
to kind of go through the process of
actively deprogramming yourself against
all these messages that are coming in so
that's that's my pitch that's mine
that's my value prop as a contributor to
public debate on economics and and more
widely that's fantastic and that's why
we wanted to have you on the show we'll
talk about economics and that academia
side of things as well
a little bit later yeah but just tell us
a little better what's happening in
Australia one of the things we talked on
this show a lot about is the culture
wars and all those kind of stuff where
are you guys with that well I think we
were in a very good place in the 80s and
90s where we led the world in economic
policy and we had a government in fact
there was a bipartisan consensus on
things like race gender and so on and
that broke down as you could you if you
were looking to blame the Labour Party
you would blame Paul Keating because he
was a who was the prime minister from 90
from 1991 to 1996 and he was very
divisive but he was still part of the
bipartisan consensus which didn't go
after culture wars but then on that on
the change of baton to John Howard as
Prime Minister it's kind of he famously
was very insightful in revving up what
seems to have been lightened in the
Australian psyche which is that if if
white Rhodesian farmers were boat people
floating off our coast I'm sure we would
have wanted to save them but if they had
brown people from the Middle East or
Asia not so much and so we've slid into
a pretty unpleasant state of affairs
where you know we're we're well we
keeping keeping people out now of course
we have to keep people out there are 60
million refugees who not all of which
could come to Australia but it's
appropriate that we don't just say any
old any old person can come in here but
the lengths that we've gone to India
humanizing people is is is a national is
a national shame and most people feel it
but there we are
it wins elections and neither of the
major parties a bit like brexit we're
the elites sort of kind of appreciated
might not be the greatest policy they
think that the people will crucify them
if they
move away from their policy so we've got
something similar going on in Australia
and do you think that that policy has
been brought about because of racism or
do you think it's brought about through
other things as well like we've had one
particular guest on who you know who
were saying you know there is because
they want to keep the reason we voted
for brexit is because we want to believe
British culture intact
do you think that is what's going on in
Australia or do you think it's more of
simply that the destroyer mode before
you answer that sorry Francis that
interview will come out after this one
so Francis has given you a tasty preview
of I into with Eric Cartman he'll be our
in a couple of ways that's what I like
about you is just advertising that's
right I'm a believer in presumptive
generosity when you're interpreting
people it makes sense to try and
interpret that you're trying to make as
much sense of what they're saying and
doing in the way they're acting is
possible and it's a perfectly legitimate
that it's a perfectly legitimate thing
to say that we've built a great society
here certainly better than many
societies around the world and we want
to protect that so so I don't have any
people who feel anxious that too many
migrants are coming in from very
different cultures I don't feel that way
but I don't demonize that I don't
demonize that at all and then there are
some racist then there was some very
small minded bigoted racists but I don't
that that's not the way I look at the
debate in Australia or anywhere else
really do you think it's cultural
essentially its cultural and it's
perfectly legitimate to say we say as
the Japanese say we are proud of our
culture and it's not compatible with too
many people coming in here because then
it'll be a different culture I think
people underestimate that they
underestimate the extent to which a
culture can remain can protect the best
parts of it and then become more
exciting we have a commentator in
Australia called Philip Adams who I
think his line is that we invited a lot
of European migrants into Australia and
found that was so much fun
we wanted more so so that's my attitude
to immigration but but you know I'm not
an open I'm not I'm not an open door
policy person either I'm in favor of her
of a vigorous and expansive immigration
program for Australia and I respect
people who want to I don't I don't hold
up the cross and say you're a racist if
people feel differently so your concern
is how those refugees are treated
essentially on well I don't want to
prison one of my concerns are
self-righteousness so it's very
important for me not to be
self-righteous about this because I'm a
privileged person who's going to say to
a desperate person sorry you're not
coming and whether I've draw that line
at two hundred thousand three hundred
thousand four hundred thousand a million
a year and at the moment it's something
like two hundred thousand a year I'm
gonna be just as much of a bastard as
anyone else so let's get off our high
horses let's try and make ourselves as
comfortable as we can be with the policy
whatever policy we come up with and we
will be making heartless and cruel
decisions nevertheless let's make them
as let's minimize that unless feel as
good as we can about it and locking up
little kids on on Islands off off off
Australia without any judicial review
that's there's nothing good about that
doesn't make people feel good I mean
numerous people have died who needed
medical attention and didn't get it
I raised $10,000 for Refugees at a party
about a month ago and a great writer of
ours Christos sulcus read the names of
those people so I feel very strongly
about this I don't feel self-righteous
about it and there's a big difference
my father was a refugee so that's
another reason I feel strongly about it
so do you think the Australian
Government is unnecessarily cruel in
their treatment of retitling well what
would you do if you have my view or
anybody else's view and you know that
there's a kid on Manus Island who's
self-harming who has pneumonia
who needs medical attention and you say
our well there might be they might be
pulling our leg they might be pulling a
stunt they probably are pulling a stunt
okay but they need medical attention and
we should be giving the medical
attention and we're not whatever I
watched rallyin comedian at a comedy
club the first job they make is about
Australia being a racist society and it
always gets a big laugh and everybody
claps and cheers is that true boys or
would you show all races so I mean you
know these tests on basketball umpires
you know I have a friend I just had I
just had cup of tea with a friend who
he's a Dutchman and he organized or he
was instrumental in organizing an
experiment on buses where people got
onto a bus and said to the bus driver
I'm really sorry I don't have any money
I just need to get to the next stop
would you mind me riding to the next
stop all right now these numbers are
made up but they're indicative so just
assume they're right for the for the
purposes the seventy one or two percent
of people had yes said to them sorry
about sixty five percent but if you were
white it was much higher if you were
black it was lower and those bus drivers
I don't think they were black hating
racists but so let's let's relax about
these things let's get let's not get too
much on a high alright start to injury
but let's move on to to economics and
you mentioned one of the things I liked
you about you among many things I like
about you is something is that you I
never know I spoke we spoken many times
I never know where you're gonna come out
on any particular issue because you
you're someone who is not ideological
and you talked at the very beginning
about how you appalled most ideology and
it drives people in well I like it as a
starting point not as a
including point and I know that it can
hijack your emotions and it gets
confirmation bias going to early in the
process if that makes sense tell us more
about that what is the impact of having
these ideologies that you see out there
and in the world and you cannot make
some politics yeah so I think this
happens everywhere and and what happens
that this may sound like a joke but what
your comedian so it'll be okay won't it
but it isn't a joke I don't know you
might you might relate to this precise
story and if you can't you can relate to
something similar when you're an
adolescent boy at high school where you
wear your belt around your hips is a big
deal if you wear it too high you're
effeminate okay it's completely
ridiculous
and in the 18th century it was different
and next century it'll be different
again but something's going on there
which has got a lot of psychological
power because it's happening all around
the world and so if you're an economist
and there's that and this idea seeks
seeps into economic policy which is a
you a free market guy or you are big
government guy then you're gonna reach
for you're going to be constantly aware
of that you're going to be aware in
meetings about how you're going down
there are going to be clicks and cabal's
unacknowledged and acknowledged and the
whole damn thing is actually run by
where you wearing your belt it's all
that it's all completely unhinged from
the merits of the situation so I don't
say that I abhor ideology I think of
ideology as both impossible to avoid and
a good starting point because it
Orient's the world but then I'm I do I
don't pick sides to be contrary or
anything like that
but I do spend a lot of my time trying
to find ways to express an idea which
don't trigger to use a word that
would work on this program that don't
trigger a response from the other side
which is our he's just a lefty or he's
just right-wing I will actually try and
work out a way a subversive way to make
a point which tries to get under those
early warning systems and trick people
into thinking for themselves or at least
not having all these incredibly strong
mechanisms doing the thinking for them
if that makes sense
and I've found that it's just been
wonderful because I'm able to wander
around and I can pick low-hanging fruit
I can say hang on well why don't we all
right say you're a free-market person
you're an intervention person forget all
that what's the problem here what if we
did that and people go you sound like
you're a free-market person I say no no
no forget that
what if we did that would that work
better than this oh you're a bit of an
interventionist aren't you no no let's
think about that and and through that
process I've I think come up with lots
of really quite actionable simple
low-cost very high benefit ideas so that
you want to give us an example okay I'll
give you an example or two so think
about the labor market think about going
and getting a job now I don't know what
the sort of language in your country is
but one of them you know labor market
deregulation is all about flexibility
people being able to move from one job
to another you've got people in you've
got people in trenches in which
flexibility means an employee and
employers right to hire and fire and and
what do you call it no listing or you
know blacklisting no no I'm talking
about but always being available for a
job and not being it so a free hours
yeah sorry zero that's right so so
that's on one side and then you've got
the Union and in Australia you've also
got quite strong labor market regulation
and you would have something like that
now ask yourself this question when I go
to a job what do I know about whether
it's a good workplace or not the answer
is nothing you don't yeah isn't that
amazing isn't it amazing that you've got
all these free market types running
around saying we should have more
flexibility and yet the absolute essence
of a market working well and you don't
have to have read economic theory to do
this you just have to have existed in
markets the essence of a market working
well is that everybody's got good
information so they can go where they
want to go what they value but is anyone
paying it any attention to that
well not that I've noticed so let's take
this let's let me ask you another
rhetorical question in fact we've got
lots of data on this cause any company
that's got more than 20 30 employees
keeps employee engagement data they're
constantly sending them surveys and I
like my boss I think my boss is a waste
of time I I think I'm well trained am I
not it's funny in those things that the
one question which everybody says
they're below average on is they're not
paid as much as they should be so the
data is there and lots of women but of
course it's also true of men might want
to prioritize a flexible workplace over
one with strong career structures or
lots of money or whatever now of course
if you go and if you go and you ask the
person you kind of work for is is this
family-friendly well then if they've
decided they want to market family
friendliness they all say yes he's our
family friendliness policy but we all
know that that's a policy and then
there's the fact and that there may be a
difference and yet we've got all this
data because they'll be polling their
own employees about how they're finding
this so why don't we release the data
well that leads that leads to the next
let me ask you why why why don't firms
release the data because they don't want
to look bad they don't want to show that
you know good you felt that's exactly
what I wanted
to say so wider the good firms release
the data I enjoy these bits of these
guests ask questions he can't answer
right so what are the good firms release
the data is it because even within that
data there will be things that they want
to hide possibly I think there's a
better answer constant teens got the
answer why would the good companies no
one release the data well I don't know
so I'm a good company so let's say well
let's let's not say I'm a good company
let's say I'm KPMG and I released some
good data and you're PwC and the data
looks good what are you gonna do is PwC
you'll have do you know what yes but
you'll have different data because
you'll be using a completely different
system together so you'll just go
through it and you'll get your [ __ ]
artists also called you know comms
people then go through it and pick bits
out of it that look good yeah and so
it's a zero so it's not going anywhere
yes because [ __ ] is coming up not
information yeah so the market failure
here is that there is no standard to
report - yeah so Teresa may could say or
Jeremy Corbyn could say who wants to
take the Prime Minister's challenge to
help define a standard or a partial
standard that we will all collect out
the first ten questions will all be the
same of anyone who agrees to follow the
standard yeah and it'll be water support
and then the best firms can release that
data
yeah and it's audible and then the ones
immediately under them are starting to
look like all the rest of the firms so
they'll release their data yeah even
though it makes them look worse than
those people it makes them look better
than all the people down there and we'll
go down now we won't get all the way to
the bottom but that costs virtually
nothing is largely risk-free
and is not ideological it's
problem-solving I'll say you are an
interventionist Nikolas and noticed that
there was no compulsion yeah so I think
if all that worked out I might I might
say oh and by the way after we've proven
up this system in five years time this
is compulsory for everyone but well you
know I might be wrong we will just have
to see but but but that's that's an
example of what we could be talking
about but no we're not because it
doesn't Rev us up because it doesn't we
can't feel self-righteousness either on
behalf of the employee or the employer
so it's not good radio not good TV not
good media let's go back to let's go
back to the trench
[Music]
she is a layperson one of the things
that I think most lay people will think
about when they think about objectivity
and balance and genuine facts and the
pursuit of truth is academia and science
and even social science to some extent
[ __ ] all right
well I know you were gonna say that
that's the one area I can't predict your
response on so how does maybe not
exactly for why I think sure because I
mean there is a fair bit of political
bias or ideological bias in the social
sciences but there's something much
worse than that which is that over the
last 20 or 30 years we've gone from sort
of leaving academics alone which gave us
an inefficient but fairly effective
system to treating academics like lab
rats in a skinner box you know and they
have to produce articles in learner
journals by a certain magnitude of a
certain number they get sacked and that
has them all running round and round
around on this treadmill producing
articles and the articles aren't worth
anything the articles are not that the
discipline their articles which build
disciplines but don't build useful
knowledge and it's a catastrophic state
of affairs there's also and so it's it's
also the case that is certainly in the
social sciences there's quite a bit of
there's quite a bit of ideological bias
that's true and generally I just think
there's too much focus on the pulse on
the slogans are you free market or are
you intervention yeah but actually I
think Jonathan Hyde talks about this in
his work as in 60s it was a ratio of
liberal conservatives to liberals in
that he was like 1 to 2 and now it's 1
to 10 on average here and in some
departments it's like 1 to 300 yeah
right so politically there's a very
strong bias as well yeah absolutely no
it's true that's true in economics it's
much less true
so economics is much more balanced I
would think in fact I don't know it
certainly I don't about left and right
which
sort of raises questions of distribution
but in terms of preferences for free
market and intervention economics is a
sort it is sort of biased towards free
markets so the way that the way the
discipline is constructed it's
constructed on the presumption that
consumers will be better at getting what
they want than anyone on their behalf
which of course makes perfect sense
unless you're dealing with the
monopolies unless you're dealing with
trickery unless you're dealing with bad
behavior of any number of different
kinds so it's actually more complicated
than that but the whole way
economics is built is to be built on
some kind of presumption that you know
do we really want to mess with this
relationship between consumer and
producer and the answer is no in lots of
cases we can realize that markets will
work well and then there are all the
interesting cases where there is
something wrong with markets but there's
also something wrong with governments
and can we evolve institutions that do
better than what we're doing now I'm not
just giving you an example of that we
don't spend much time talking about that
and is that the impact of this kind of
way of thinking that the real world
problems don't get solved as don't we
have these battles that's right so I
couldn't the the descript that the the
idea that I presented to you I couldn't
put that in a I couldn't publish that in
an economic journal without all kinds of
basically idiotic modeling because
they'd go argue well that's an idea but
you need to it needs to be more than an
idea so what happens is that the
discipline ends up looking at things
where there's lots of data so that's the
old business of looking for your keys
under the light even though you lost
your keys down the road where there's
lots of data where it's possible to
build sort of toy economic models of
people interacting now in this era in
the area that I get the example that I
gave you the reasons why people don't
have good information about work places
us kind of it's sort of subtle and it's
not
very easily susceptible to simple
modeling and most simple modeling just
assumes that people know what they need
to know and that they have the cognitive
power to do whatever calculations are
necessary and I think you would say I
would hope you would say commonsensical
e that's not the case there so we should
be able to just jump off from that piece
of common sense if someone wants to come
along and challenge it that's fine we
should be able to jump off from that
common sense and then start looking at
this as a possibility and oodles of
other ideas so we were talking a little
bit about how we've seen in academia a
gradual shift towards the left ins not
particular Kannamma --cz but in some
departments do you think that's a
problem that's certain institutions are
way over to the left and why well
because the that because these things
should be starting points not answers
and because yeah we've got a whole lot
of people running around lecturing other
people about essentially nothing about a
bunch of talking points about a bunch of
slogans disastrous so what do you mean
by a bunch of slogans well what we've
got the recent example of fake papers
being published if you learn the
techniques and it's hard work to do it
you can get fake papers papers published
you can get fake papers published in a
surprisingly large number of areas now I
happen to have the view that there are
whole fake sub disciplines where they
cannot within economics so real business
cycles is based on the idea that the
Great Depression was a spontaneous
holiday taken by tens of millions of
workers but people have won the Nobel
Prize for that work okay it's not
no one's exposed as a fake because the
mathematics is all correct but the basic
assumptions are just visible you were
laughing at them yeah this happens in
economics all the time and sometimes you
what makes silly assumptions because
they kind of get you to somewhere which
is fertile but that's really not what's
happened in economics what happens in
economics is that it's the what this
analogy I made with where you wear your
belt you there are disciplinary
protocols one of them I won't I don't
think it's worthwhile boring your
listeners have with it too much but one
one of these protocols is that you
shouldn't build a model of the
macroeconomy the way the whole economy
is working without micro founding it in
other words without building an
elaborate structure which goes all the
way from individual agents and deduces
from that macro responses now the
problem with that is that we all know
that we are members of a herd we all
know that we are ignorant when we make
an investment or when we buy a fashion
item and we all know that there is a
degree of emergent herd behavior that's
a [ __ ] micro foundation okay but it's
not in mathematics that sort of micro
foundation was already there in Keynes
in John Maynard Keynes but it became
fashionable Keynes was wearing his belt
too far up is too far up his waist and
he looked like a dill according to
current fashions and so we developed
this proposition that a model is worse
for not having micro foundations and a
particular kind of micro foundation off
with the fairies but they were those are
fake papers and people got Nobel prizes
for it so things are a bit more serious
than a few fake papers in social science
in some of the more left-wing social
science disciplines and you say it's a
bit more serious how serious are we
talking about here well it's it's it's
eight point one on the nichols growing
series
recommend about 8.1 that's where I'm
thinking it's a very serious situation
and and and everyone will I can't count
the number of times the number of
conversations I've had with young
academics who say yeah yeah I know all
that and I'll play with a game for a
while and I'll become more influential
I'll change it I respect that I mean
that's a interesting worthwhile mission
to give yourself but we've heard that
from politicians too and and and I see
this as there's something very
unsatisfying about it now you could say
there's something unsatisfying about
what I've done which is to go and try
and look at problems on their merits
which is a snake oil salesman way of
saying I don't know what I mean I try
and be as rigorous as I can I talk to
people who know the feel better and so
on and I and when people ask me what
does lateral economics is it does it is
it does it focus on energy or transport
or macro or labor market I say yes it
does
but we try to look at things on their
merits and I'm sorry that sounds like
you know that doesn't say very much but
I haven't even given you an example of
the sort of thing that we try and find
which is just something that people
haven't been talking about or thinking
about which offers actionable
high-impact kind of results well that's
what you've been talking about is not
attaching yourself to a particular way
of thinking but rather looking at the
reality what can we do about this and a
discipline is a set of tools it's a set
of it's a set of repertoires a set of
instincts all of which could can be
useful and all of which can be
questioned and which need to be
assembled carefully for any particular
question and it will be assembled
differently so we find talking about a
school system as opposed to a hospital
system there will be elements of
similarity and then we'll always be
elements of difference and we should try
to
follow they'll follow the merits of the
situation and use these these ideas that
that of the Reno discipline and in other
disciplines to try and come up with good
ways of reacting well you alluded to it
there was a story by the time discuss I
will be a couple of weeks ago we're with
Peter pegasion and Helen Clark rose on
this other guy who they they took a
section of mine camp they threw some
feminist feminist buzzwords into it yeah
and they got peer-reviewed and published
in the journal yeah incredible well dogs
and right culture yes yeah it's it's a
joke it's a joke what can you say it's
it's it's we should all reflect on it
because if it's that prominent mean we
can say haha I mean quite a few of these
kinds of papers economists are very
they're quite a lot of economists who
are very superior about that as if you
know that wouldn't happen in economics
it's true that doesn't happen in
economics big but but mathematically
defended nonsense happens in mathematics
it happens in economics all the time it
shows that how ignorant we are and how
respectful of our own and everybody
else's ignorance we ought to be well I
mean I take a bit of an interest in
business people because they've well
some of them might have just got lucky
but it's remarkable how often I mean
this is true
Elon Musk says this and Charlie Munger
and Warren Buffett said that say this
which is we make most of our money
mostly by trying not to be stupid not by
being trying to be very clever and
that's not what academics do academics
don't win any prizes for not being
stupid they win prizes for showing how
incredibly clever they are even if it's
in the service of something which is
ultimately stupid
so it's interesting an interesting
little paradox and I wouldn't want to
get too self-righteous about any of it I
mean I did a drama degrees
you know a lot of [ __ ] well let's
move on to politics you had some I've
always just enjoyed listening to you
talk about the political side of things
that kill Konami tonight you know you
you've often said that we've done two
politics what McDonald's has done to
nutrition yeah what do you mean by that
so I think our culture is besieged by
fast-food ISM if you like so that the
the paradigm example is we is fast food
and we evolved on the African savannah
and we evolved certain appetites and
tastes and culture and cultural
practices and they meant that we liked
food that was sweet that was rich that
was salty that didn't disgust us and if
you do that on the African savannah it
keeps you away from poison you know meat
that's gone bad and and it works well
for you and it also works well for you
as human beings are revolving and
getting richer they then start to create
food for themselves that that is more
expensive because it's richer and so on
and then at some point as people start
to optimize to sell the food this these
instincts betrayus and toxified and I
would argue that over our whole culture
that we are and this is in a sense what
I was saying about academia that we had
optimized certain things about it to the
point of toxicity we've gone from an
inefficient but effective system to an
efficient but ineffective system and in
I mean so so if you take the fast food
example you if you think that McDonald's
is - McDonald's is - food
porn is to sex and what modern politics
is to what we imagine politics should be
so modern politics has been optimized
with an inch of its life people who were
selling a political message and I was
talking to somebody yesterday about
brexit and she was saying well we know
what emotional message to resume we'll
go with if she gets a deal from Europe
what's our emotional message and I said
to her yes well Adolphe Hitler said of
course I reserve reason for the few and
emotion for the many and our politics is
so optimized around emotion around
entitlement around resentment this
country's famous for having a prime
minister who told people they've never
had it so good I think that was in the
late 50s that didn't go so well for him
truth-telling isn't a great idea so so
but that was the late 50s or 60s and now
it's got so much more like that so much
more trivialized so much more sense
that's sensationalized and again people
blame the Internet and of course the
Internet's a very important part of this
story but it's also very important to
realize at least for me I was on I was
very upset and concerned about democracy
before the internet and the best stat I
can give you on that is that a
non-american TV the length of a
soundbite went from 48 seconds to 8
seconds from 1968 to 1988 and we're not
going to survive as a democracy with
sound bites of eight seconds we have to
be able to we have to recover reason in
our politics and I wouldn't even really
be going on about this except that I
think that we can do it except that I
think I have an idea which can
powerfully detox the situation that
we're in otherwise I'd just be kind of
grizzling on and I'd rather focus on
things that I think I have some I think
I can make some kind of contribution
well that's what we'd like to do here
chicken okay so the world's probably one
conversation well for us so I believe is
so I think the the basic idea is to
understand that there are in fact two
ways of representing the people there is
an older way of rep
you can have direct democracy we
actually now now in some sense that they
had direct democracy in Athens in two
and a half thousand years ago but we
might get back to that but we since the
internet we actually have the technology
to go back to direct democracy can you
imagine getting home from work going
onto your internet and saying oh okay so
the we're going to change the weight
that a nurse can lift in a hospital from
five gillard kilograms to three and a
half kilograms tick I don't know so so
that's one way and people are enamored
of the idea that direct democracy might
be a good thing because that plays to
our vanity because politics is all about
everyone telling the people the people
are good and the politicians are just
the politicians are just tricking them
well who votes for the politicians as
Bernard says when Prime Minister hacker
says to umber note it seems that the
civil service exists simply to prevent
politicians implementing the sacred
promises they made to the people well
somebody has to so I don't think direct
democracy is the answer I think director
I'm Optra see could quite possibly make
things worse definitely so we've gone
with a representative system but the
representative system that we've gone
for makes us feel good and makes us feel
that they're doing what we want because
they compete for our votes that's
representation by election there is
another way to represent the people you
might not since you haven't read my
stuff I'm going to ask you again what's
the other way to take subsets of the
subsets of the community who will be
representative of the community and we
do it right now we did it in ancient
Athens and we do it right now it reminds
me I used to be a teachers this is what
I did to Kate when they didn't do their
exactly I'm making it a feature not a
burden was one of you have done your
homework you have any bad school by the
way you're wearing you built a little
home by far in the way the best episode
of trigonometry we will ever I don't
even know the question I'm representing
the people now as we represent the
people how can we find another way of
just pick or getting 300 500 people to
represent all everyone in Britain well
the love Francis thinks about this why
don't you have a thing if you come up
with the right that's right so boys
another way so they did it in Athens
they're doing it in Britain now doing it
in courts
so the jury so it's jury system yeah
that's it so you just get ordinary
people and you say what do you think and
that changes everything
it changes the idea that this group is
an elite it only becomes an elite as it
learns so a jury is a cognitive elite
for the case at hand because I've been
sitting there for the last 12 days and
they've been learning but they represent
the people and if 12 people good and
true or whatever it's supposed to be say
that a guy's guilty you don't feel the
need to you know we don't have lots of
talkback radio about how we were ripped
off by those rotten jurors we go well if
it was good enough for them they might
be wrong but it's good enough for me
because that's the best we can do yeah
we don't do there are their politicians
because we have hooked up the idea of
representation to merit merit has been
toxified by all the dark arts of of
politic elections force politicians to
fight each other
they can't become a politician without
beating another politician so they're
not going to say we'll hang on we've all
got to fix this problem they're going to
say well if I say that I'll say that
they'll say I'm tough on crime and
that'll get me more votes because
everybody's feeling really bad about
some horrible murder so so that toxify
is our politics in a jury it's all
completely different in a jury people
listen to each other they're kind of
keen to compromise they so let me take
you through the psychology of someone
being invited onto a political jury so
now I'm talking about what's called
citizen juries why don't you outline so
that's one way of doing it at the moment
unsewn
is so let me give you an example of
Oregon in Oregon the state of Oregon in
in the United States they have citizens
initiated referendums and in 2011 I
think it was or perhaps a year or so
later they had an referendum on
mandatory sentencing now who's not in
favor of mandatory sentencing if if you
are convicted of a felony sex offense
I'm sorry to pick on you any sex offense
on four occasions do you think there
should be mandatory sentencing yeah good
if you are convicted it was 25 years in
jail if you are convicted of drunk
driving on three occasions do you think
there should be mandatory sentencing
yeah you know I didn't even have even
that's interesting you said yes I didn't
even tell you what the sentence was yeah
but the sentence is three months in jail
now I answered yes to both those things
70% of Oregon of people from Oregon
believed that was a good idea and a
citizen's jury was held 24 people meet
for one day per weekend for four weeks
four days and after that process and we
have to assume the best guess is that
70% of them were four and
thirty percent were against what someone
decided and after that process the
twenty four people voted 21 against and
three four so obviously now you can
easily imagine I don't know what the
difference was but I presume you could
take someone through a possible quite
felony sex offense which actually wasn't
such a big deal that you would put some
away someone away for twenty five years
I don't know what that was but I do know
and I have a lot of faith in ordinary
people if I hear that I think well that
was probably a dodgy bill so so that's
the idea of a citizen jury the
psychology is different it's more
democratic than than our electors and so
on now how would you know I guess yes so
so I want to kind of lead a movement of
demanding a citizen's chamber now
citizens chamber would be several
hundred people chosen at random and the
one thing that it would do is it would
take our I just ever so slightly off the
opinion of the people and give us
another view of the considered opinion
of the people which in the case of
mandatory sentencing is the difference
between you know 15 or 16 out of 24 and
3 out of 24 a huge difference and if
that had been the case in Australia I
think I'm over whelming majority of a
citizens of normal people when they
learnt that we were abolishing carbon
pricing which would now be contributing
to our budget over ten billion dollars a
year and keeping carbon emissions low
and maintaining government services or
lowering taxes elsewhere that was so
much so much better policy than the
policy we implemented that it wouldn't
have even happened if we'd have had such
a chamber because the parliamentarians
wouldn't have had the nerve to put
through such a shitty policy and I think
exactly the same thing would be true of
brexit here because the difference
between the opinion of the people on
brexit which we know is fifty to forty
eight in favor or at least was in June
2000
Dean is about 60/40 the other way when
you give people enough time to learn
about the issues and kind of decompress
from the Daily Mail and the sun's
endless propaganda about you know the
shape of bananas and peak fat in ice
cream and various other things but I
just I'm a Democrat but I'm not a
Democrat on McDonald so I want a
Democrat on I want to be a Democrat on
proper on proper nutrition and one of
the things you've talked about as well
as the consequence of not having this
kind of thing and having dis McDonough
lized politics where it's sound by it's
another inauthentic politicians is that
in some ways someone like Donald Trump
who in many ways many people would say
is deceptive but they're you've talked
in the past about how there's an
authenticity these kind of deception is
quite different he is not I mean
everyone knows that he doesn't tell the
truth everyone knows that he's like a
little kid in a playground who makes
stuff up all the time but he doesn't
optimize what he's saying he doesn't get
a bank of comms people and PR people to
say this is good for all Americans or
one of those kinds of things so that's
so people relate to that because
remember in this optimized sort of
politics we're keeping people away from
their reason and and instead encouraged
or canta all the all the all the signals
they get our emotional signals and it
seems to me and this is just some
amateur pundit REE from me but it seems
to me that people relate to Donald Trump
speaking candidly as he does as he does
he tells people when he stuff things up
he I mean not all the time not when he's
saying he didn't stuff them up
he could say anything but he's and I
don't defend a guy I think he's a he's a
nightmare a complete nightmare but but
I'm addressing myself to why
he is as successful as he is and I think
people hear those talking points hear
those focus-grouped slogans and just
they've had enough it's like running
your fingers down a blackboard people
are now I may just be projecting my own
frustrations on to the and on to the
great mass of the people but I just
think people absolutely hate all that
they get it in advertising they get it
all the time and they know what they're
getting and they know that it's chunk
the thing they haven't owned up to is
that they vote for that chunk I wouldn't
get it if it didn't work isn't the
reason people voted for Trump people
voted for Boris Johnson to be mayor is
that they seem like a version of their
authentic self so people go oh I know
who this person is yes I can then make a
decision it's more Jacob Riis mug is
actually quite popular it's quite like
watching his quite lot like watching him
because I I sort of liked the way he
speaks people tell me is pretty batty
and I think his views on brexit are
probably batty but I don't really know
enough about it but he's he's he knows
what he thinks he's he's pretty
straightforward about what he thinks
certainly the things I've seen him talk
about he's an old this is almost extinct
he's extinct in Australia but he's a
Burkean conservative he's a he that just
oozes out of every pore and he's every
pore in his being so yeah people like
that and but you know there are there's
lots to like about us and that's the
thing is that people look at him and go
I know who Jacob Riis mug is yeah
therefore I can make an informed
decision whereas before in politics you
looked at a lot of these people got and
you'd go I don't know who you are
hmm but for better or worse I think I
know who Donald Trump is hmm well yeah
but that's for worse yes yeah yeah I
mean that ultimately we're making these
very difficult decisions but yeah that
that's that's the power of this
authenticity and of course you know
these people are quite skilled at it you
know that line that you know if you can
fake sincerity you've got
you know the main thing in the show
business is authenticity once you can
fake that that's right so it so they're
all pros they're all professionals and I
kind of like the the really good proof
that the people who know that and then
use all of that knowledge to project
something of some value but it's it's an
off again we are getting ourselves into
a situation where where we are expecting
such heroism about politicians
well how's that going net you've
actually given the example in the past
of an Australian politician who went
from being perceived as coil and
authentic yeah we want to be yeah so
you've given that example yeah so Julia
Gillard I think and I know Julia are a
bit and I she was the last nice guy we
had as Prime Minister since John Gorton
who you will never have heard of but he
was back in the back in the early 70s
but
Julia went from being a feisty
forensically intelligent deputy leader
with fiery red hair to being a talking
point zombie sorry about that Julia and
I had this little fantasy and the
fantasy was that I traipse around after
her as a staffer for her because I've
worked as a staffer for other
politicians and she'd come out of an
interview and I'd she'd say how did I go
as they tend to and I'd say [ __ ] ask
Julia here's a here's a DVD when you get
home you and Tim watch this and you'll
see a real master at work and when she
got home she put it in and who would it
be but herself and it wasn't even going
to be her former self it was a
particular format that she continued to
be very good at which was QA which is
people from the audience asking
questions and she was tremendously all
those things a little less feisty but
but
compelling calm intelligent warm fun
knocked it out of the park so here we
had a kind of superstar in Waiting who
possibly partly because of the woman
thing possibly partly because she was a
woman was feeling under some kind of
pressure to do act in a certain kind of
way I don't know that's pure speculation
from my point of view she couldn't quite
do it I think she got quite a lot better
by the end and by the end it was too
late but that's my bit of that's my bit
of a mature explanation for how julia
had a great honeymoon made some sort of
obvious political mistakes as well and
one of which was to be too honest when
people said you've in from you've
introduced a carbon tax and you promised
not to and the correct political answer
was well it's not a carbon tax it's with
carbon permits and that's the sort of
answer that John Howard would have given
and he wouldn't have got out of it the
stupid still would have been some
pressure on him but it was sufficiently
but but it turns out I think in
hindsight that the right answer was to
dissemble a bit and and what Julia
Gillard did was said yeah okay you can
call it a carbon tax I made that I made
the promise in good faith I had to run a
government in coalition with the Greens
and this is what we've come up with and
it's a good policy anyway so she made
some actual political mistakes which
some people could argue with a reason
for her not going so well I think it was
this inability to remain authentic
through all the spin masters and all the
pressure and and and and pressure
perhaps that she put on herself she has
a fantastic memory as well and on one
occasion she gave a speech almost
word-for-word perfect with the speech
sitting in front of her without looking
at her notes and I think she did a bit
of that what she did my opinion she did
a great deal too much of it with talking
points that she had in her mind that she
would return to them to ad nauseam and
and on one occasion when she was going
for election there was a slogan which
was moving forward which was used 61
times in two speeches and then it was a
joke I could have told her that so so
she she was an authentic politician and
she presented herself as a as a talking
point Zambia sighs as i unkind Lee said
she's watching where you fellows at
King's College so I'm gonna see you next
week with anyone all right
no you won't beat you out of showing the
spot in the last question we always like
to ask has been fascinating to have you
on the show is what is the one thing
that no one's talking about that we
ought to be talking about the details so
we're not so much the details but not
those two things in the polls but not
not the opinion polls the left and the
right polls that's what we should be
talking about if we're whatever we're
talking about find something of interest
find something you might be able to make
better and forget about all the Archie
barge you flying backwards and forwards
and see if you can think of ways to make
it better and then grow a group of
people around the idea who will agree
with you fantastic thank you so Francis
might say something else oh thanks
Francis yeah it's been great to have you
on if you enjoyed this week's fantastic
episode as always subscribe to the
channel click that Bell button let
Francis do the social media yes follow
us on Twitter pod we are on Instagram
Twitter Facebook also as well um we're
starting to get a little bit long
reviews on the item so leave us a nice
review tell us what you think um
yeah please do and that'll be it and
thank you again for watching or
listening and we'll see you next week
bye